I have a chat. I have a chapter on this in the book, and I talk about how, uh,
th th the most manic of, of these individuals, uh,
are according to research are incredibly us anti-social and they can't tell if
it's the chicken or the egg,
is that their own beliefs and ideologies that make them antisocial,
or is it something about them that makes them that way?
And when you look at what's going on in his,
in the streets of Portland and Seattle, there's,
there is a mental issue going on there. They do not seem stable.
So I think that these are people that have lost contact with their loved ones,
their family.
I don't think these are people that come home for Thanksgiving and help with the
Turkey.
As a guy that just wrote a S you know, a self-help,
it's a self-help mockery in a way, but it's also,
but it is self-help at the same time. What do you think it is about that time?
Like,
what do you think the dividing line is between a type of person who wants to
take care of themselves in their life versus the type of person that wants
to, because we see so much of this everywhere, just take out of it.
There are people, well, I have a chat, I have a chapter on this in the book,
and I talk about how th the most manic of,
of these individuals, uh, are according to research are incredibly,
uh anti-social and they can't tell if it's the chicken or the egg,
is that their own beliefs and ideologies that make them antisocial,
or is it something about them that makes them that way?
And when you look at what's going on in his,
in the streets of Portland and Seattle, there is,
there is a mental issue going on there. They do not seem stable.
So I think that these are people that have lost contact with their loved ones,
their family.
I don't think these are people that come home for Thanksgiving and help with the
Turkey, right?
I think that their joy in life is to humiliate
and attack. And have you hear their screams in their cries?
I do think that we're living in an age of hysteria,
and I think it's also bleeding into other certain segments that I can't even
talk about certain activists who do not represent the people they
claim to. There's a great, um, Oh,
there's a great clip of this African-American cop in Portland talking
about how black activists came up to him and said, Hey, you know, um, you know,
how do you feel about George Floyd?
As he's talking a white leftist female comes over and goes,
don't talk to him. She's telling a black woman not to talk to him.
And you realize, okay, this is a, this is a mental issue. This is, uh,
so I think that you almost have to pull them out of this cult,
you and I aren't in Colts because th th the measure of a cult is the ability to
admit when you're wrong. Like I admit I'm wrong on like,
at least once or twice a year now once or twice, like we were pretty regularly.
Um, uh, well, it's.
Not only do we admit Greg, Natalie, do you admit you're wrong?
Can you tell the good people,
what happened this very week on the Greg Gutfeld show with you and cows?
You made a major, a major admission.
Yes. Uh, emission, nice one or omission, EMIS. And, um,
I might've, I I've noticed this, that,
um, we all have, and even Adams has said this, but he wanted a bit, what, what,
what mistakes that we have these like really embarrassing things that we,
that we won't voice, because we're, for example, in Seinfeld,
it was George SCA. It didn't want to go to a flea market.
Cause he thought there were fleas. I always thought that I thought that too,
they'll do a flea markets in Belmont, California, and my friends want to go,
I go, I'm not going there because I thought so too.
I have two idiotic beliefs in the last month that I've talked about one on the
five. I thought deal was a separate animal.
I didn't know that it was like a baby cow. No idea.
I thought like when you order veal,
it's like ordering lamb or it's just a different animal. So that's a bear thing.
But I didn't know that cows were only female.
I thought that a cow was just like, there was a man, so that's stupid.
But it's like, I, I don't mind confessing that. I know these things.
I I'm an idiot because I know for a fact that everybody,
everybody feels that way. I mean,
there are people that think that there might be 52 States, uh,
because they get confused between a deck of cards and the United States.
And also you have those two States that are outside. Sometimes I'm going like,
is it 52 or 50, 52 or 50?
I should check because I get confused. You know, is it 48 plus two it's 48.
Plus it also, there are things like when you think about geography in general,
that you can get stuck totally wrong because, uh,
you kind of skipped over it and somebody could trick you into thinking that
something was part of something when it really wasn't. Um,
there are parts of Europe that I might've thought were parts of other places.
But it's all of that is all of that. Really?
Just because everyone seems to pretend that they know everything at all
times, net neutrality was going to kill. Everybody,
sold him on his death was going to start world war three. You know,
there's some, the Russia thing, the Ukraine thing with the Iran, nuclear deal.
People who have no jobs, no people who can't get their lives together,
but they know everything about string theory and economic policy, you know?
Yes. I try to do that. You know,
who knows EV I'm convinced you knows everything. According to his fans,
as John Oliver manage usage, his 30 minute on net neutrality,
it'll change your life. It's like, no, thanks. I'd rather be ignorant. I don't,
I don't think I need to know 30 minutes on net neutrality because I know where
it's going to end up in the same place. It always does. And to your point,
it's always the same place. And I think it's helped like, like string theory.
This is like,
this is the blessing and curse of podcasts that you can do your curriculum.
I'm going to learn about quantum physics and quantum mechanics or quantum
gravity put quantum in front of everything. And suddenly people like, Ooh,
who is this guy? But I enjoy I quantum leap. Yes.
I love that actor. There was Scott.
Cut back. And Oh, the other guy, the other guy.
Who played booth, uh, who played Mr. Booth and blue velvet.
Who was, he was in green hair. He was in the movie boy with green hair.
He was an air force one. I just watched it this weekend. Uh.
Oh God, geez, Louise.
If only somebody here could Google the boy with green hair, that Jew.
Did you see that movie as a kid? Do you ever see that movie as a boy?
He wakes up with gray hair.
I don't think I've seen it. Very scary.
Amazing. I saw it as a child probably came out in the 1940s, 1950s,
but the guy we're talking about, Stuart stew, Stan,
uh, uh, step, uh, George.
We should do it. You know what I'm going to do? Wait, Greg, watch this.
I'm going to do something. I've never done this on my show before,
but my director is remote right now. He's in my ear, Matt.
I want you to Google the actor that we're talking about. He was in quantum leap.
He was not Scott back ULA, but the other guy,
and apparently he had green hair as a child. Can you get me that actor's name?
This is the most cable news I've ever been right now.
Yeah. And he was the guy that ran the bordello in the dark. Well,
Dean Stockwell. I hope he's still alive. Do you start well?
Did you, do you ever see blue velvet?
Wait, hold on. Let me go back to the control room. Matt is Dean.
Stockwell's still alive. Yes.
Stand by Greg. I hope he is
still alive. No. Wow.
He's 84 and still alive. At least as of this taping.
Road trip, we are going on as Dean stop. Did you?
I have to ask you because it's my favorite movie of all time is blue velvet and
these Stockwell's character was the guy that ran the whorehouse that Dennis
Hopper came to. And it's one of the greatest scenes in any movie.
Um, anyway, that's mine. Did you wait,
you look like you've not seen blue velvet.
I actually, I haven't seen it. Believe it or not, but Gutfeld. I got to tell ya.
I love ya.
But your movie recommendations over the last couple of months have really been
disastrous. Um, I'm texting you one morning. I'm like,
I don't know what we're going to watch tonight. I've watched everything.
You're like, Oh, you got to watch the color of something with Nick cage.
I literally, I got brain damage in the middle of the movie that horrible.
Whoa, wait a minute. Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
That's the port of call with Nicholas? No, no,
no, not the color. His face. It's, it's a remake. The, uh, the, um, officer the,
um, fire. I can't swear right now because of, you know,
you can square it square. People will like it.
It was a remake of a Harvey Keitel movie, but it really wasn't.
And it's called Porter call and it's by the guy who did grizzly man, um,
the director, um, who did grizzly man Werner Herzog did it.
And it's called, um, cop officer bad Lieutenant port of call.
And it's got li iguanas in it. How could you not love that movie?
How could you not love that movie? The Nick cage. It's what a Nick cage,
his best films, the cage. Also, if you've ever you didn't like Mandy, did you,
Mandy, what are you?
Yeah, I tried to watch that because of you two.
I watched it for about a half hour and I couldn't take it anymore.
I was sitting in a pool of my own vomit and I thought I got.
All right, wait.
This is what you call a tangent.
This is the beauty of YouTube that you don't have the luxury as a,
as a cable news host to do these, do these things. Um,
actually I wanted to ask you about something somewhat serious, actually,
because just in the last couple of days, uh, you know,
Tucker did this end of the show monologue about what the New York times is doing
Ram. And they've basically, they've basically threatened to dox him.
They already did one version of this,
and we know that people have shown up at his house before and all that. Uh,
I feel that this is the next level of where this is all going,
that they've said, it's okay to burn down stores, violence. Isn't violence,
words are violence, but violence is, and it's very confusing,
but the next level of this will be that it will be,
it will be something to the effect of can Republicans go to public
places and can Republicans have homes that are not doxed?
Or are you worried about that? Like what, what do you make of this thing?
Oh, um,
I'm worried in a number of ways that I've actually acted on it. Uh,
for the last couple of years, actually I've acted on, uh, on certain things to,
to for safety reasons. And we've talked about that before. Um,
I find it interesting that all the things that you talked about are okay,
but they're charging that couple for brandishing,
that weapon when the mob approach broke down the gate and was in front of their
house. So they're actually not only can you be threatened,
not only can your, uh, public and private property be vandalized,
but you cannot defend yourself.
You're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.